Welcome to another Read Your Jeans Podcast and we're going to go over the questions that you said in or whatever if you do have questions about your genetics or about anything with your health and welcome to ask them on the box on the Read Your Jeans.
Those couldn't directly to me. We had some community here.
Question number one, when can I stop taking the recommended supplements for my genetic defects?
Well, you could do whatever you want to do, but understand that your genetic defects are going to go away. So the genetics, the supplements that I recommended are really for a lifetime because you're going to have a lifetime of those defects.
Is there ever a good other question, might be, is there ever any to review those? Well, there certainly need to look at your overall health and there may be other needs that need to be addressed. Remember your genetics are not, you know, the only thing that's going on with you.
With you, you have epigenetic factors of things that's in your diet and your environment and your, you know, lifestyle choices that can affect our health much more than your genes. So looking at an overall picture of your health is really important to
you genetics are just a piece of that. But as far as what I make the recommendations, I make it kind of ties to the next question too. It's based upon what's going on with your genetics.
It doesn't change. So let's say curcumin was recommended because of, you know, a lot of inflammatory gene defects. Well, then, you know, that's something that you probably want to consider stayed on long term. So that's how I put those those together for you. So it's not something that you're going to fix.
But you kind of ties these are from the same person. So how come you don't recommend supplements for every defect, it's kind of the same thing. You're not treating the defect.
So you're really looking at when I look at your genetics and looking at what are the most important things because everybody has defects. Right. So if you're going to put supplements protocol together for every single defect, you'd be on a hundred different supplements.
And that's just not reasonable. And it's certainly not even necessary. So we do look at is let's say if I have, you know, the pun one family, which has to do with phase two detoxification pathways. If I have a lot of double the effects in that family of genes, well, I definitely want to be supporting that super important genetic pathway.
You're not able to get out what's on the inside as far as your toxins go. You're going to end up with issues that even possibly cancer. So probably one of the most common pathways, probably one of the most common pathway on issues that we see with our cancer patient.
You're definitely need to address that. And again, it ties back to that earlier question, address that long term. So you just, you don't just support that for a period of time. You stay on a product like our, our phase two assist or called one assist on a regular basis because you need to support that pathway.
And look at dietary change. So it's not just taking supplements, but looking at the dietary changes that we recommended as well.
Then the kind of ties to this question, we get this question a lot. Are there ways to heal from genetic issues or are there ways to heal my genes. People ask that question. How do I get rid of these gene defects that are common question. Well, I alluded to that already. You don't, you know, these aren't going to go away.
And they're going to be with us. Now, there are some practitioners out there that say you could heal your genes. If you do this and that.
But if that was true, it would be readily objectively proven because you could just run another genetic test and those defects aren't there anymore. Well, that's never happened.
So your genetic pathways can get worse. So if I did a genetic work up two years ago and that I was exposed to, let's say, a lot of toxins because I don't know, you know, in the next two, you know, a farm that sprays with pesticides constantly.
Could my genes get better ever? No, even if I do everything right. Could they get worse? Yes. So I could have more defects from that toxic exposure the last two years. So if I ran my genes again today, I could actually have more defects.
So toxins, poisons in our environment can damage our genes in those damage genes don't go away. And the problem is, is that if I'm still having children, those I will pass on those damage genes to my children.
So, and that's how, you know, our species has more damages as time goes on. And so the things that we're doing to ourselves, you know, in the last 50 years with the amount of poisons that we're exposed to, the amount of drugs that we're exposed to, the toxins that are air, the toxins that are food that's damaging our genetic pathways is damaging our genetic pathways from here on out into.
Throughout the species, throughout time. So that's the sad part, and that's the scary part thing. We have defects that are great, great, great, grandfathers or grandparents never had because of our exposure to toxins that they don't feel.
Well, I hope that was helpful. That's our last question that we had for today. I'll make sure you get your questions in on the course. And we'll do our best to answer them. And now if you have specific questions that you'd like to talk to me about, make sure that you just call the clinic and make an appointment with me.
We can do a 15 minute consult now with all our course members. So take advantage of that if you want more person and care. All right, thanks.